in this lesson you will be learning the
concept of ensemble learning by the end
of this lesson you will be able to
explain ensemble learning evaluate the
performance of boosting models overview
ensemble technique combines individual
models together to improve the stability
and predictive power of the model this
approach permits higher predictive
performance compared to a single model
ensemble finds ways to combine multiple
machine learning models into one
predictive model in order to decrease
variance using bagging decrease bias
using boosting or improve predictions
using stacking let's understand the
ideology behind ensemble learning as you
have seen before certain models do well
in modeling one aspect of the data while
others do well in modeling another
instead of learning a single complex
model learn several simple models and
combine their output to produce the
final decision in ensemble learning the
combined strength of the models offsets
individual model variances and biases
ensemble learning will provide a
composite prediction where the final
accuracy is better than the accuracy of
individual models
ensemble methods can be divided into two
groups
sequential ensemble methods and parallel
ensemble methods in sequential ensemble
methods bass learners are generated
consecutively that is adaboost the basic
motivation of sequential methods is to
use the dependence between the bass
learners by weighing previously
mislabeled examples with higher weight
the overall performance of a model can
be boosted parallel ensemble methods are
applied wherever the bass learners are
generated in parallel for example random
forest since the errors are often
reduced dramatically by averaging the
basic motivation of parallel methods is
to use independence between the bass
learners here in the given diagram we
are using parallel ensemble method where
the different models work best in one or
other aspect of data they are combined
in the ensemble model where the best
aspect of each of the models is
considered upon the input data and then
ensemble learning model comes up with
the predictions
ensemble model is the application of
multiple models in order to obtain
better performances from a single model
performance depends on two major factors
robustness and accuracy ensemble models
incorporate the predictions from all the
bass learners this provides robustness
ensemble models deliver accurate
predictions and have improved
performances ensemble learning methods
part a you can create an ensemble by
combining all week learners once week
models are properly combined we can
obtain more accurate and/or robust
models you can also create an ensemble
of well chosen strong and diverse models
by combining data from numerous modeling
approaches ensemble models gain more
accuracy and robustness than a
fine-tuned single model can gain model
averaging is an approach to ensemble
learning where each ensemble member
contributes an equal amount to the final
prediction in the case of regression the
ensemble prediction is calculated as the
average of the member predictions in the
case of predicting a class label the
prediction is calculated as the mode of
the member predictions in the case of
predicting class probability the
prediction can be calculated as the Arg
max of the summed probabilities for each
class label a limitation of this
approach is that each model has an equal
contribution to the final prediction
made by the ensemble there is a
requirement that all ensemble members
have skills compared to random chance
although some models are known to
perform much better or much worse than
other models a weighted average ensemble
is an extension of a model averaging
ensemble where the contribution of each
member to the final prediction is
weighted by the performance of the model
the model weights are small positive
values and the sum of all weights equals
1 allowing the weights to indicate the
percentage of trust or expected
performance from each model
now let's take a look at what bagging is
the idea behind bagging is to combine
the results of multiple models to get a
generalized result from a single model
bagging or bootstrap aggregation reduces
variants of an estimate by taking the
mean of multiple estimates there are
three steps to perform bagging step one
is to create randomly sampled data sets
of the original training data
bootstrapping step two is to build and
fit several classifiers to each of these
diverse copies step three is to take the
average of the predictions to make a
final overall prediction ensemble
learning methods Part B let's understand
how random forest is an ensemble
learning model random forest is a good
example of ensemble machine learning
method random forests as one can guess
combine various decision trees to
produce a more generalized model by
reducing the notorious overfitting
tendency of decision trees random
forests are utilized to produce D
correlated decision trees
it creates random subsets of the
features smaller trees are built using
these subsets creating tree diversity to
overcome overfitting diverse sets of
decision trees are required boosting is
a sequential process where the errors of
the previous model is corrected by each
subsequent model let's assume an example
of different types of body pain and
their diagnosis headache
stomach pain and leg pain will have a
different reason let's assume that X
causes headache then X will not cause
leg pain because Y causes leg pain these
two variables are not the reason for
stomach pain stomach pain will be caused
by variable Z depending on the results
of weighted opinions the doctor will
suggest the diagnosis sequentially let's
understand the way boosting works in the
steps flow step one is to train a
classifier H one that best classifies
the data with respect to accuracy step
two is to identify regions where age
produces errors and ways to them and
produces a h2 classifier step three is
to aggregate those samples for which
each one gives a different result from
h2 and produces h3 classifier repeat
step two for a new classifier let's
understand what adaboost is and how it
works let's first understand boosting
boosting is a technique of changing weak
learners into strong learners in
boosting each new tree is a fit on a
modified version of the original data
set adaboost is one of the first
boosting algorithms to be adapted in
solving practices adaboost helps you mix
multiple weak classifiers into one
strong classifier let's understand this
through a scenario consider a scenario
where there are plus and minus symbols
indicating the data points we will try
to understand adaboost workflow working
of adaboost so the first step is to
assign equal weights to each data point
and apply a decision stump to classify
them as a plus or minus the most suited
and most common algorithm used with
adaboost is a decision tree with one
level these trees are short and solely
contain one decision for classification
they are often called decision stumps as
you can see in the given graph decision
stump d1 has generated a vertical plane
at the left side to classify the plus a
decision stump is a decision tree it
uses only a single attribute for
splitting four distinct attributes this
typically means that the tree consists
only of a single interior node now apply
higher weights to the incorrectly
predicted three-plus as shown in the
given graph and add another decision
stump you can see that the size of three
incorrectly predicted plus is bigger
than the rest of the data points in the
second step the second decision stump d2
will try to predict them correctly so as
you can see d2 is classified three
misclassified plus correctly d2 has also
caused
in error - three - in the next step
d3 adds higher weights - three - a
horizontal line is generated to classify
+ into - based on higher weight of the
misclassified observation in the final
step d1 d2 and d3 are combined to form a
strong prediction that has complex rules
as compared to the individual weak
learners adaboost algorithm and flow
chart now since you know the workflow of
adaboost classifier let's understand the
adaboost algorithm a weak classifier is
prepared on the training data using the
weighted samples only binary
classification problems are supported so
every decision stump makes one decision
on one input variable and outputs a +1
point 0 or minus 1 point 0 value for the
first or second class value the MIS
classification rate is calculated as
error equals correct - n divided by n in
the given equation error is the MIS
classification rate correct is the
number of training instances predicted
by the model and n is the total number
of training instances so let's
understand the steps involved in this
algorithm step 1 initially data points
is weighted equally with weight WI
equals 1 over n where n is the number of
samples step 2 a classifier h1 picked up
that classifies the data with minimal
error rate step 3 the weighted factor
alpha is dependent on errors e.t step 4
wait after time T is given as this
formula where Z is the normalizing
factor h1 X YX is the sine of the
current output let's understand the flow
of adaboost algorithm it follows the
following steps one initially adaboost
selects a training subset randomly - it
iteratively trains the adaboost a
machine learning model by selecting the
training set based
on the accurate prediction of the last
training three it assigns the higher
weight to wrongly classified
observations so that in the next
iteration these observations will get a
high probability for classification for
also it assigns weight to the trained
classifier in each iteration according
to the accuracy of the classifier the
more accurate classifier will get higher
weight 5 this process iterates until the
complete training data fits without any
error or until it reaches the specified
maximum number of estimators gradient
boosting now let's understand gradient
boosting gradient boosting trained
several models in a very gradual
additive and sequential manner the major
difference between adaboost and a
gradient boosting algorithm is how the
two algorithms identify the shortcomings
of weak learners that is decision trees
GBM minimizes the loss function MSE of a
model by adding weak learners using a
gradient descent procedure gradient
boosting involves three elements one a
loss function to be optimized to a weak
learner to make predictions three an
additive model to add weak learners to
minimize the loss function let's
understand the GBM mechanism gradient
boosting trains many models sequentially
each new model gradually minimizes the
loss function of the whole system using
the gradient descent method so in y
equals ax plus b plus c he needs special
attention because it is an error term
the learning procedure consecutively
fits new models to produce an additional
accurate estimate of the response
variable the principle idea behind this
algorithm is to construct new based
learners that might be maximally
correlated with negative gradient of the
loss function associated with the whole
ensemble so let's understand the working
gradient boosting GBM predicts the
residuals or errors of the prior models
and then some
them to make the final prediction step
two one weak learner is added at a time
and existing weak learners in the model
are left unchanged
step three GBM repetitively leverages
the patterns in residuals and
strengthens a model with weak
predictions step four modeling is
stopped when they do not have any
pattern that can be modeled let's look
at the steps involved in GBM algorithm
step one fit a simple regression or
classification model step 2 calculate
error residuals that is actual value -
predicted value step three fit a new
model on error residuals as target
variable with the same input variables
step four add the predicted residuals to
the previous predictions step 5
fit another model on residuals and
repeat steps two and five until the
model is over fit or the sum of the
residuals become constant XG boost let's
understand extreme gradient boosting it
is a library for developing quick and
superior gradient boosting tree models
XG boost is one of the implementations
of the gradient boosting concept but
what makes it unique is that it uses a
more regularized model formulation to
control overfitting which gives it
better performance thus it helps to
reduce overfitting extreme gradient
boosting is a custom tree based
algorithm used for classification
regression and ranking with custom loss
function it has interfaces for Python
and R that can be executed on yarn XG
boost is extensively used in ML
competitions as it is almost 10 times
faster than other gradient boosting
techniques let's understand the XG boost
library features XG boost library tools
are built for the sole purpose of model
performance and computational speed
let's look at system features followed
by algorithm features we will finally
take a look at the model features of XG
boost system features our
parallelization
parallelization it produces tree
construction using all CPU cores while
training distributed computing it uses a
cluster of machines in order to Train
very large models cache optimization
data structure involved in X G boost
makes the best use of hardware algorithm
features are sparse aware algorithm
behind XG boost provides automatic
handling of missing data values block
structure it supports the
parallelization of tree construction
continued training its algorithm
provides continued training in order to
boost an already fitted model a new data
model features our gradient boosting it
uses gradient boosting machine algorithm
including learning rate stochastic
grading boosting it does subsampling at
the row column and column per
split-levels regularize gradient
boosting it does regularization using
both l1 and l2 regularization XG boost
parameters part a let's understand the
XG boost parameters general parameters
consist of a number of threats that
helped to prepare data task parameters
correspond to the objective that helps
to build a model evaluation metrics help
to predict and visualize the predicted
values booster parameters consist of a
step size that evaluates the prediction
performance metrics and ROC curve and
regularization that compares the
prediction performance against the
logistic regression model let's
understand the general parameters of X G
boost general parameters guide the
overall functioning of X G boost so
let's understand what these general
parameters are n thread is used to
define the number of parallel threads we
are going to use if no value is entered
the algorithm automatically detects the
number of cores and runs a thread on all
the cores booster parameters guide the
individual tree or
aggression at each step there are two
types of boosters which booster can you
use GB tree uses tree based model GP
linear uses linear function usually a
tree booster outperforms the linear
booster silent default equals zero is
used to print the running messages if
the silent parameter is set to one
no running messages will be printed
hence keep at zero as the messages might
help in understanding the model
let's look at the booster parameters
booster parameters give the individual
booster tree regression at each step
let's look at the parameters for tree
booster first ETA defines the step size
shrinkage used in update to prevent
overfitting after each boosting step you
can directly get the weights of new
features and ETA shrinks the feature
weights to make the boosting process
more conservative ETA range is between 0
& 1 and the default value is zero point
3 gamma defines the minimal loss
reduction required to make a further
partition on a leaf node of the tree the
algorithm will be more conservative when
the gamma is larger its value ranges
from 0 to infinity and the default value
is 0 max depth is used to define the
maximum depth of a tree its value ranges
from 1 to infinity and the default value
is 6 min child weight is used to define
the minimum sum of instance weight
needed in a child if the tree
partitioned step results in a leaf node
with the sum of instance weight less
than min child weight then the building
process will give up further
partitioning in linear regression tasks
this simply corresponds to the minimum
number of instances needed in each node
the algorithm will be more conservative
if the min child weight is larger it
ranges from 0 to infinity and the
default value is 1 XG boost parameters
Part B
max Delta step is used to set the
maximum Delta step allowed in each trees
weight estimation if the value is set to
zero it means there is no constraint if
it is set to a positive value it can
help make the update step more
conservative usually this parameter is
not needed but it might help in logistic
regression when the class is extremely
imbalanced its value ranges from zero to
infinity and the default value is zero
subsample is used to calculate the
subsample ratio of the training instance
its value ranges between 0 and 1 and the
default value is 1 call sample by tree
is the sub sample of ratio of columns
when constructing each tree subsampling
occurs once for every tree constructed
its value ranges between 0 and 1 and the
default value is 1 now let's understand
the parameters for linear booster lambda
defines the ridge regression
regularization term on weights
increasing this value will make the
model more conservative the default
value is 0 alpha defines the lasso
regression regularization term on
weights increasing this value will make
the model more conservative the default
value is 0 lambda bias defines the ridge
regression regularization term on bias
increasing this value will make the
model more conservative the default
value is 0 now let's look at the task
parameters task parameters guide the
optimization objective to be calculated
at each step the objective options are
binary logistic defines logistic
regression for binary classification
whose output is probability not class
multi softmax defines the multi-class
classification using softmax objective
evaluation metrics for validation data a
default metric will be assigned
according to the objective our MSE for
regression error for classification and
mean average precision for
banking the evaluation metric options
are rmse log loss error AUC mirror mlo
gloss demo Pima Indians diabetes problem
statement the objective of the data set
is to diagnostically predict whether or
not a patient has diabetes based on
certain diagnostic measurements
including in the data set all patients
are females of at least 21 years of age
and of Pima Indian heritage the data set
consists of several medical predictor
variables and one target variable
outcome predictor variables include the
number of pregnancies the patient's have
had their BMI insulin level age and so
on let us import the required libraries
including pandas and model selection
from SK learn also we will import
adaboost classifier from SK learn dot
ensembl to further optimize our model
import pandas import SK learn import
model underscore selection
from SK learned ensemble import at a
boost classifier
now load the data set with a panda's
data frame
extract the values from the columns in
the form of an array
set the random seed value a seven and
number of trees as 30
we will build classifiers using adaboost
and XG boost let's create the adaboost
model using s CI kit learn
adaboost uses decision tree classifier
as the default classifier
past the model within the
cross-validation score function to
evaluate the results using the cross
validation technique
construct the model now by splitting the
Train test indices into ten consecutive
folds again evaluate the model such that
each fold gets used once as a validation
while the remaining nine folds form the
training set print the results
adaboost gives an accuracy of 76%
similarly we apply the XG boost
algorithm import the respective modules
namely SVM and xgb classifier from SK
learn import SVM
from XG boost import xgb classifier
initialize the xgb classifier under the
name CLF set the seed value a seven and
number of trees is 30 construct the xgb
classifier using the k folds technique
such that number of folds equals ten
evaluate the model using the
cross-validation score similar to the
way we did for adaboost classifier
you
again the accuracy is around 77% we have
shown only two classifiers you can use
different classifiers and compare the
results also check results after
applying 10-fold cross-validation great
we have seen how to apply boosting
algorithms to classification let's
quickly recap the steps we covered one
build models using adaboost and XG boost
to compare the accuracy of classifiers
model selection when do you need to
evaluate the model performance models
can be evaluated based on measures of
performance model evaluation aims to
estimate the generalization accuracy of
a model on future data that is unseen
out-of-sample data so model evaluation
techniques are used to evaluate the
models performance when there is a
chance of evaluating new data that is
unseen or out-of-sample let's now look
at how to access model performance train
test split or cross-validation split are
the techniques used to evaluate the
model performance train test split
divides the training data set into two
sets and uses the first training set to
train the model and tests the model
using the second set cross-validation
split splits the data set in two sets
namely train and test and then
calculates the accuracy of each set and
finds the average of the results let's
look at how train tests split works so
we have a given data sets that we need
to split into training data and testing
data split the data randomly using
negative and positive symbol now when
you have training data randomly selected
from the given data set the remaining
data falls under the tested data move
this data into the hypothesis space make
sure that your test set meets the two
subsequent conditions given the test set
must be large enough to yield
statistically meaningful results the
test set must have different
characteristics than the training set
now verify the result by
matching the train data with the test
data now test the training data
individually with respect to the test
data present in the hypothesis space
wherever the data that has the same
symbol matches it provides accurate
result prediction given here is 913
which shows the matching prediction
common splitting strategies so let's
understand what percentage of data
should be used for training and for
testing so we can use either of the two
common splitting strategies to split the
data k-fold cross-validation or leave
one out let's first understand how
k-fold cross-validation works the
procedure contains a single parameter
referred to as K and points to the
number of groups that a given data
sample is to be split into as such the
procedure is usually referred to as
k-fold cross-validation when a
particular value for K is chosen it's
going to be employed in place of K
within the relevancy of the model
so how does the leave one out technique
work
this approach leaves one data point out
of the training data that is if there
are n data points in the original sample
then n-1 samples are used to train the
model and one point is used as the
validation set all the combinations are
created in this way the original sample
can be separated and the error is
averaged for all trials in order to
provide overall effectiveness now let's
understand the difference between train
tests split and cross-validation
advantages of cross-validation one it is
a better estimator of out-of-sample
accuracy two it provides a more
efficient use of data since each data is
used for training and to testing
advantages of test train split one runs
k times faster than k fold two simpler
than k fold so it would be easier to
analyze the testing errors demo
cross-validation problem statement a few
learners have implemented random forest
classifier on the iris data but better
accuracy can be achieved by using the
cross-validation sampling technique in
this analysis we will generate the
random forests using the
cross-validation splitting technique let
us import the inbuilt iris data set from
the SK learn dot data sets library
from SK learned data sets import load
underscore iris
load the data set with a data frame
you
extract the input data
similarly extract the target values
k-fold cross-validation use the k-fold
cross-validation technique to split the
data set into k consecutive folds
without shuffling by default here we
will split the data set into five
consecutive groups from SK learned on
ders core selection import kay fold
you
using a for loop we will now iterate the
individual train test sets within the
input data
let's now split the data set into ten
consecutive folds
using a for loop we will now iterate the
individual train test sets within the
output data
you
let's initialize the random forest
classifier from SK learn dot ensemble
import random forest classifier
you
import the cross-validation score
library from SK learn and get the model
evaluated for accuracy by using the
cross-validation score parameter from SK
learned all under score selection import
cross underscore vowel underscore score
you
the accuracy of the classifier is 95
great we have seen how to apply cross
validation to split the data set let's
quickly recap the steps we covered 1
shuffle and split the data set randomly
into K groups to summarize the skill of
the model using model evaluation scores
this brings us to the end of ensemble
learning you are now able to explain
ensemble learning evaluate the
performance of boosting models hi there
if you like this video subscribe to the
simple learn youtube channel and click
here to watch similar videos Dinard up
and get certified click here